so
i'm happy to announce thomas um so
i think both in life as well as in our
little filter bubble of data science
there's a couple of topics that
definitely deserve a little bit more
attention
and if you're in data science what i
think is one of the more
underappreciated topics is drift
and like shifts in populations because
you can have a great model
but then the world changes and then your
model's not that great anymore
um so with that in mind thomas i'm
very curious on what you have to say on
the topic go ahead thank you
so uh hello and greetings from london
actually thanks max and vincent for a
great discussion
it was very interesting to listen and uh
yeah it's my pleasure to have you here
guys
and also thanks for the invitation for
the pi data
so uh i want to present here something
that we use internally at ing
and since it was very useful for us we
thought it would be also
very helpful to share this with the
community so today's presentation is
about population shift monitoring
also a so-called covariate shift problem
so that basically distribution shift
in the independent variables
distribution
and yesterday there were quite some
questions regarding the data quality
monitoring so
hopefully this presentation can answer
some of those or maybe this package
could be helpful for those people
and as you can see probably from the
name of this package uh it stands for
population marketing popmon
uh so shortly about me myself uh so i'm
thomas fostech i'm a data scientist at
ing
specifically wholesale banking advanced
analytics
and i've worked there already for one
and a half years
and the first half of my career at ing
i've been focusing on this
basically solution of population shift
monitoring
and as a result we came up with the
package
that we would like to present in this
presentation
and uh yeah the basically the short
outline would be uh
first we're going to talk about the
motivation the problems
of the population shift also
present the pop popmon solution i'll
give a
short demo i'll also show that the
result of the library
what does it actually of the package
what is actually the out uh what's the
output of the
package and also the internal use case
after applying this on our own ing data
so roi was we have noticed that our
machine learning models and data were
not being monitored
carefully enough and after looking at
some open source solutions
we haven't found any that would satisfy
all of our criteria
and since we had past experience in
doing this right we have decide
decided to implement our own solution
and some further motivation why we would
like to do this
we would like to have reliable and
consistent models in production
and we would like to be assured that the
incoming data and predictions are
consistent with the historical data on
which model has been trained
and tested initially and why it is
important is because if input features
change
then we cannot guarantee that the test
performance
will be the same as described in the
model design
and also we will we would like to have a
full control of continuous retraining of
deployed models
so we wouldn't have to think twice for
example if the
if when the data has changed whether the
performance will stay the same or not
um we need to know that the distribution
of the new data
is similar to the old one and if it's
not does it actually affect our
final performance of the model and it's
also as a bank especially it's very
important to
store as many intermediate results as
possible
so if some reporting is done or audit
it's always good to have some paper
trail and some
basically some
some performance results and some uh
data
aggregations to to be to be able to
backtrack
why your performance went down or how
you are developing your model
so probably uh you're familiar with
these issues these are some common uh
data issues which
would namely would be population shift
data route and time dependencies
so population shifts we are discussing
here in this presentation
data route would be something that for
example if you have
data which is too old and you don't want
to use it anymore in your data set
because it's not
in your train data since it's not
relevant anymore
and time dependency issue because
sometimes
you're training on the train data but
you're not taking into account that
there might be some seasonalities
or a trend going upwards so for example
some distribution is going up
or down and distributions are changing
over time so you would like to take this
also into account when building your
model
um we also split monitoring in three
main parts
which in this case are data monitoring
predictions monitoring and model
performance monitoring
so for model performance there are quite
some solutions
it's quite some open source solutions
that we have already tried ourselves as
well
and namely ml flow and seldom and others
probably have heard about those
so this uh this basically part is
covered quite well but what we haven't
found
uh to to be covered is basically data
monitoring and predictions monitoring
to be frank ml flow and seldom they try
to cover but
they do cover basic data profiling
which is tracking mean and standard
deviation of the data
but as you'll see from some of the
examples
later this is not enough if you really
want to see if your data is changing
over time
so that's why we decided to focus on
these two problems which are also quite
similar
uh if you'll you'll see that in the next
slides
so here you can see basically in this
image
how the data points are shifting and
therefore the histogram of the data is
changing
however the data profile stays exactly
the same
so here you can see on the bottom the
box plot
so basically data profile you can see
mean and standard deviation of the data
and even though there is a very big
shift in data points
and data distribution in general the
data profile doesn't show that at all so
if we would be tracking this
and say okay so our data doesn't change
so our model performance shouldn't
change
no that's not right because our data is
actually changing we're just not
monitoring it
correctly so another two examples uh
how we would like to visually inspect
the data so for example if we train data
on
uh in this case trained data on the left
side is a
red histogram if we train on this data
and later try to apply our model but as
our data has shifted so our incoming
data our test data
becomes the blue one we will we
shouldn't expect exactly the same
performance as
if the data would be in the shape of the
red data
which is the trained data and also on
the right on the right side we can see
the data in 2d
so basically you can see two features
here
and you can see that trained data is
very different from test data so if you
once again if you train your model on
train data and your test
data starts to shift starts to drift
away you would like to notice this
and to retrain your model or together
with the train data or just on the new
test data
depending on your use case and this is
only two dimensions on one dimension
imagine if you have a lot of dimensions
and a lot of features and you would like
to
maybe track it more automatically
because you cannot inspect all these
changes visually for all these features
and over a different period of time
especially when your models are deployed
and
running maybe for many years and the
data is constantly incoming
so we have developed our pipeline so
basically this is
one of the core structures of popmon
so we get some new data which is
incoming constantly incoming
to our package we histogram this data
and then we have
we we can have we can also compare to
the previous test data
but we can also have some trained data
separately
which we know is good so we would like
to compare our test data to that
data so we apply a bunch of statistical
tests i'll show you later
and from those statistical tests we get
a bunch of metrics
on which we apply different thresholds
which are set by business rules
and from there on we get alerting in our
reports
so basically we can inspect what has
happened in our data
and how the histograming works so for
example if you don't have the reference
data
we can also just compare this uh data to
uh to itself basically if we have some
some let's say one year of data we split
this data
per week and we want to see if this data
was consistent over each week
so for example if we zoom in on week one
we want to compare if the week two is
similar to week one
and how do we do this we overlay this
data on top of each other
[Music]
and we get two histograms on top of each
other and we can see that
they're quite different
and we can visually see it and as i said
it's yes it's very manual process but
how do we
actually make it automatic and more
tangible
so we apply a bunch of statistical tests
like in this case a pearson correlation
could be applied chi squared commodore
smirnoff
and also many more tests we have applied
some
or implemented more tests from different
papers
and we have made a this functionality of
implementation your own test
very easy and intuitive in our package
so you could try
and go and try your favorite statistical
tests
as well and you would ask why histograms
so histograms are very useful because um
it contains a lot of aggregated
information so
basically it's it's good for us
especially when you work in bank and or
when you work with a lot of consumers
data
you want to avoid to have data privacy
issues and histograms aggregate this
information so basically it's difficult
to
link this data back to a specific person
also it's good for size so basically
histograms are very lightweight
so it's easy to store and also light for
sending over apis so imagine you don't
want maybe to send
the data to a server where pop on is
running you would basically would like
to maybe
first create those instagrams which
would be very lightweight to send them
over api so you don't
leak your data the the api is very
fast you don't burn too much internet
bandwidth
because yeah you have to send so much
data as in like sending
gigabytes of your raw data and
also monitoring works identically with
both big and small data because in the
when you when you put it in the
histogram it doesn't matter how many
rows you had before
if you still have the same number of
bins your account basically will just
change
um so in in in the in the say
in the case of monitoring this is very
beneficial because it doesn't matter how
much data you have
the pre-processing will take some time
yes but after this is done
it's as fast as big data as with small
data
and it's also more visual it has a lot
of information
so you can immediately see distributions
of data from histograms
and also as we saw from before useful
for applying all sorts of
statistical tests
so we thought we touched now like data
monitoring but if you look at the
prediction monitoring problem and
specifically if you have for example
posterior probabilities
as an output from your prediction model
this can be interpreted
very similarly as a data monitoring
problem
because we can histogram same
probability the same probabilities
and just input this as a feature as
as a as a data feature basically and
apply exactly the same statistical tests
you can see the trans is the mean
actually shifting of this histogram do
we get an improved performance
overall in these type of things so this
is very powerful
very powerful and for more advanced
users and cases of this library you can
even
later correlate this data this these
probabilities to
changing data so that's also a very
interesting
use case so popmon is useful for both
data engineers and data
data scientists as well as data analysts
of course
so it's great for data exploration you
can immediately see data patterns
trends seasonality outliers uh
it's also very valuable for early
inspection of cabarets
but it can also be used for data
ingestion pipelines
so you can monitor your incoming data to
prevent drop in performance so for
example
as we already discussed if the test data
is doesn't look the same as train
data we cannot guarantee the performance
of our model and also we have made
stitching available so basically if we
already applied some
monitoring on some data and you have
more data incoming in batches
so over a certain period of time or over
some
records so let's say you have a batch of
1000 records
you can basically stitch it to existing
data
and apply a pop on on it and see if this
a new batch
is actually similar to the data you've
seen before if it's not
you would like to alert and look into
that data
so uh recap on some of the concepts one
of the concepts was profiling so
we we also do store basic statistics
such as mean
standard deviation median uh also but
also we apply a statistical comparison
statistical tests and also we have
multiple reference points
so for the profiling part your favorite
statistics
um also statistical tests on histograms
in the statistical comparison sky
squared komodoro smirnoff
but what i would like to zoom in here is
that we have multiple reference points
so you could say
as already mentioned you can look for
example
the incoming data you can compare it to
the previous incoming data so let's say
this new batch you can compare what was
the last batch and those look similar
the data in the new batch or you can say
you have a hold out
trained data set that you compare your
newly incoming data
set to you can also say compare a new
batch of data to
let's say rolling sliding window of 10
last batches the mean of 10 last batches
of that data so yeah different reference
points
for different type of business purposes
and we also have so-called concept
traffic lights
which is the way we alert so there are
two ways of alerting uh one is
stating uh static and one is more
dynamic
so the static basically would be you
define the rule and you say if data is
outside of some range so let's say
between 100
and 1000 if the value is outside of this
range we want to alert
but this is very uh tricky because you
would have to define these
specific rules for each feature
which can be a very cumbersome and also
it might be it might be very difficult
because data is also changing over time
so what we propose is also dynamic
uh configurable bounds which are defined
by uh
standard deviations so we remove this
burden from user to actually
uh specify those traffic light bounds
and how it works basically we convert
uh the data points into this into
basically standard scores
so we take each bim so here if you see
this plot
we get for example a mean of histograms
over time so we have here 52 weeks and
we compare how this make
how this mean of each week compared to
the reference data that we have
somewhere
left out so how do you compare this we
take
mean of each week so basically each of
this bin
we subtract the reference the expected
value
of the reference data and we divide by
standard deviation of this reference
data
and based on that we can plot this data
you can see in the right plot
and after setting the configurable
monitoring bounds
you can see that some of those data
points are outlying
but that's uh specifically for this
presentation because
we set those configurable balance quite
low just to see that
it's actually working and some data is
outlying but
ideally in the perfect world uh those
cases would be a bit higher
maybe and those those configurable
rounds would be like four and seven
so that we catch real outliers
and yes two maybe just as a quick
explanation
how the future plots will look like so
because before i presented
histograms per week so in the the other
plaza we're going to look at
it's going to be a more overtime because
we uh
we convert all those we histograms per
week
into some metrics so for example in this
case we confirm
we profile this week so basically a
histogram of one week into the mean
so we say that's uh this first bin is
the mean for that week
and that goes over time so if we have
some
training data so let's say our reference
data
we try to create those
expected how do you say the the mean for
the reference data and the standard
deviation for
reference data because based on that
we'll evaluate the
the outliers of our new incoming data
so after doing this after getting mean
and standard deviation of this
reference data we apply those traffic
light bounds on the new data
and once again because we set a bit
lower thresholds
and we get quite some outliers in this
case six outliers
however this is just to demonstrate the
purpose
and how this all works so we use
reference data to define those traffic
light bounds
which are automatic and based on that we
alert
in our uh potman report which i'm gonna
present soon
uh so once again yeah podmon got
released in april 2020
so it's very recent but it already has
got quite some handy features
so just a short summary before we move
on to the demo
so i would suggest using popmon yeah to
monitor visibility of pandas or spark
dataset
it helps automatically detect changes
over time transshifts peaks
outliers anomalies it's very handy to
have an alerting base in these dynamic
business rules
it's also very easy to extend you can
make your own data pipelines i'll show
later how to do it
and you can also implement your own
statistical tests and it will
automatically show up in your report
and so far we looked more into 1d
histograms so basically
for per one feature but you can also
create features basically 2d histograms
from two features and more
so how how would you use pokemon uh in
this case
it's a very simple example we import
some uh data sets so in this case a car
insurance data set which is fake data
set
and just by importing pokemon we
basically extend
the pandas functionality and we add an
extra function which in this case is
a pop one stability report and just by
calling this function
and specifying your date column or batch
column
you can basically get the report and
simply output it in the jupyter
notebooks just by calling
this variable which stores the output of
the function
here is even simpler example so
if you already have your data frame
somewhere
before in the previous steps in your
jupyter notebook or anywhere in the code
you can basically import potmon call
this function
and with this additional function to
file you can
basically store your html report so no
internet traffic is required this is
also works offline
so once you have this html file all the
libraries all the libraries are in the
file so basically you can send it over
and it's going to work for everyone so
this has been
quite some talk uh i'm just going to
show you
how it looks like in real life
so basically this is the popmon report
uh i apply this popman
library on kaggle dataset this is
basically flight cancellations and
delays datasets from 2015.
and so you can you might be able to see
quite familiar features here
once again we get our
on the x-axis we get the time access or
could be also batch
depending how you define our problem but
in this case it's time we histogram our
data per two weeks
so in this case we can see that count so
basically the number of
flight cams flight cancellations or
flights happened
for two weeks it was around 2000
so that's how you should interpret these
these bar plots and this this is quite
handy because you can immediately
see all the profiles that you can
actually also define yourself
so some basic statistics
um you can here easily change features
so something was
interesting here that i immediately
noticed from this data and which also
makes sense
is that you can see that cancelled
gets value one or zero and that
we see the spikes in cancer flight
cancellations
around the period of christmas or in the
winter period
because obviously uh there are more
flights cancelled
due to weather conditions so this can be
obviously seen from this data
and based on our traffic lights you can
see that this data is outlying
it's above the yellow line so something
we could
look into something that would be
interesting for us to look in
if we train this on if we train our
model on this data
another section is so this section
basically
entails all these uh statistical tests
that i described
so chi-square here so it looks a bit
cryptic but uh once you get a grasp of
it
so it becomes very intuitive so
basically you can see how
the chi squared was changing over uh
different weeks
so here we compare each week with the
previous week that's what i call
previous
uh so for example if you look at
cancelled we can see that some
weeks had very odd behavior so
we would like to zoom in zoom in maybe
on these specific
weeks and look what have happened here
we can also see it to the reference data
so ref chi
square so we can also see that
in the winter periods those uh
basically there were more flight
cancellations
um also with something a bit more handy
is the immediate traffic lights so you
can see that
if you got any yellow or red lights
so here you can see red because uh those
last
bins didn't have enough data but that's
also good indication that our last badge
didn't have enough data so
good for testing purposes um
but you can also see that there were a
bit more uh
odd behavior in winter here regarding
cancellations
also we have more aggregated alerts so
here you would like if you would like to
see everything for all the features
so number of red alerts number of yellow
and
green alerts and also if you would like
to expect the histograms itself
so for example in this case we had
airlines and how
do those air like how do how do those
histograms compare to the previous week
and to the reference
data so in this case we compare the
airline distribution so basically
specific american airlines
how does this distribution change over
those weeks
and also we can see how the cancelled
data has changed and it's more
interesting also airtime
so this is the report
and also i want to show something extra
here so basically if we go here uh
in our github and open this link and get
in
in collab i've actually executed this
for us
to make it quicker so we also install
here popmon
we read the data we show the data
this is also some dummy data and we
would like to generate the report
it just works here out of the box in
google collab
so basically we call a stability report
we say which features we want to see
so in this case we specifically specify
what we want to see
but if we don't defy define features
here it would basically just create all
the features from the data frame and
also
you define time width that you want to
see like over two weeks or every month
or every week
so it depends if you have some prior
knowledge about your data and the
seasonalities and these type of things
maybe this is a bit more uh handy to
configure this
beforehand so this is the report we're
going to skip this for now
but what it's also very interesting that
we don't necessarily have to work with
this report if you don't like the report
and but you like the functionality of
this
uh library this package uh
you can basically just use the output of
this uh so basically by calling the data
store
because we store in the data store we
store all the intermediate results
so same profiles comparisons uh dynamic
bounds and all these things
we store them in data store and we can
basically plot them ourselves here on in
singular plots without
need uh without need to run the whole uh
reporting stuff uh so here for example
if we
look at the data store specifically
profiles we can see what keys we have
so these were the features that we
defined and let's say we want to see all
the profiles for
the age for our future age so we get
all the profiles mean standard deviation
and quantiles
all this kind of stuff if we want to be
a bit more specific we say okay we're
interested in these and we want to
inspect that
this is data over time so basically as
we have defined it's uh
it's been per two weeks and we can
easily plot this
ourselves without need for the whole
report
so just in a couple of lines we have got
this
nice and handy plot
so let's come back to the presentation
so you might be wondering how do you
create
[Music]
such pipeline one myself so a more maybe
maybe a bit more custom report and here
i'm presenting a very simple pipeline
so what you basically have to do is the
importing
the building blocks which are important
on top
you can define your business monitoring
rules it also works if you don't define
them because we have
some good automatic
monitoring rules which in this case
would be 7 4 -4 and -7 as well
but i just left it here just for the
demonstration that it can be easily
changed
and then if you look a bit below you can
see the datastore object
which is basically dictionary in this
case we it's it serves as an
intermediate state so when we uh
when we apply these modules in our
pipeline you can see that in the list of
modules
for example his splitter that these
modules have
different arguments such as arith key
and storky and these are basically
referring to the place on datastore
where to store
the output of this module and where to
pick data from
so basically these modules are picking
data from datastore and outputting in
there
that's where we were able to basically
play with our data even after
displaying the report because all this
data is being stored the intermediate
data
and then you can play with this data and
do further research on that
um yeah as easy as this you can add your
own modules as well
and attach extra profiling functions so
in this case we basically just
split histograms we profile the data
we add one section because in the
previous report we saw
all five sections and this in this case
we generate very simple reports would be
just profiles
would be even quicker to generate such a
report maybe
for some users it's even more relevant
to have such a short report without
all those traffic lights and i also
promise to present an internal use case
so we have by using popmon
and applying it on our own data we have
observed a peak in our data set
so once again here the x-axis is time
and y-axis was a chi-square test and we
have noticed that
at some point some weeks our data
started look different
very different from the previous data
and we started wondering why
and this is basically the peak and after
going to
uh and this peak happened around
september 2018 and we were wondering
what happened with this data and after
going after doing some investigation for
the investigation and data and talking
to data owners
we're told that the data source has been
switched to a new data source
and before we were training basically
our model on all these data so
also on the new date on the old data but
after getting these insights from the
business owner
we basically decided to retrain only on
the new data
and we have noticed a significant
improvement in the performance
so which helped us to improve the model
and business a lot
in general and yeah as you can see this
is almost the end
what the future holds for us uh we're
spreading the word about this package we
have put quite some more
we have put quite some work in this and
we are also going to use this
within ing data quality pipelines
because we value this package and i
think it's very useful
for these type of tasks we have recently
open sourced it
so a lot of new features are still
coming up
for example as you can see here on the
bottom we have
we have came up with this temporal
plotting of histograms by using heat
maps
so in this case you could easily debug
by visually inspecting
your histograms going over time so this
would be some
additional feature that we would like to
add to the reports
and uh but yeah that's just one of the
features and
we would also like to integrate this
more with other packages such as airflow
so you could get
reports let's say scheduled to be uh
made every
every week every two weeks and just on a
regular basis
and especially very very valuable for
audits and
as i said paper trails if you don't want
to run it yourself every time
and also we would like to incorporate
this together with the ml flow
which we already mentioned is very good
for uh performance monitoring
since uh our our package is not
currently doing this we are very open
for ideas and contributions
and yes feel free to try to implement
one of your favorite tests
in our package and yeah
the last thought are you ready to give
your data the attention
it deserves thank you